for people who are watching this man
like what would be you know
aspiring artists right who maybe have
been grinding independently and ain't
ain't really getting no traction what
would be some advice you'd give them as
somebody who's
stayed down and like you said you have
you know outside of this record you had
another record that was really big you
know what i mean
keep working keep working and believe in
yourself if that's what you think
if in your heart you feel like that's
what you're supposed to do
keep working because you got to believe
in yourself you got to believe in
yourself when i was
i i remember like
i think tupac had just died
and i told my mom i'm going to be a
rapper
like
what you're going to be when you grow up
everybody i said i'm going to be a
rapper astronaut
it was one of the two i don't be a
rapper or an astronaut it's the only two
things i ever wanted to be so
i knew i was going to be a rapper for
sure at what point in time did you
realize being an astronaut would
probably be the toughest probably like
probably like a day later
and not a lot of those
yeah i realized it was kind of i was
kind of low-key you know
you might be able to pay to go to space
soon enough